you've heard the saying don't just
bucket thomascook it
but I daresay you've also heard the news
that after more than a hundred years of
trading the Thomas Cook doors closing
for good and whilst of course
inconvenient many affected holidaymakers
the real victims here are the members of
staff twenty-one thousand of them nine
thousand of which a uk-based they've
been demands that the British government
should have stepped in to save the
company and jobs
but while the sentiment is
understandable it would be the wrong
thing to do thomas cook whilst a much
known and loved brand was a failing
business one which was mismanaged and
was bleeding cash from its eyes its
demise was only a matter of time giving
failing companies the security net but
government will bail them out when it
all goes wrong is a one-way ticket to
disaster i suppose i grieve you
Thomas Cook has been in trouble for a
decade you know and government I mean
with the ones I think he's got 1.6
billion of debt yeah 1.7 billion of dead
why didn't the debt holders stepping why
didn't the debt holders couldn't the
extra 200 million to 7 because they
didn't think that was it would survive
well they thought the Chinese would do a
deal didn't yes and they thought the
Chinese would do do Charlie wouldn't do
a deal the debt holders didn't put the
money didn't put the money in now I
suspect if the government have put the
money in
let's not believe that would have been
the end of it the money would have been
required further and further now the
only possibility I think in these
circumstances was for the government to
take it over its government but I doubt
with the you've got that sue the the
shareholders or all the debt Hong Kong
get it but but that's the I was the only
possibly I you put in 200 min you said
for that I buy the whole thing yeah and
the house and this and thence goes but
even then I wouldn't even be happy with
that I mean it lost one point four
million one point five million in the
first six months of this bleeding cash
and in the end that's what big all
businesses or businesses that go bust
usually go buskers they've got no
they've run out of cash it's a 19th
century business trying to survive in
the 21st century impossible
Gregg you're the most experienced
business person here what do you think
the board should have been doing about
these guys bonuses they took 20 million
47 million over ten years okay well in a
few years they're taking large amounts
do you think there's a there was a
problem in the governance here I mean I
mean what would you out of their
remuneration committee someone who's
chairman of the vehm cover very big bank
and trying to control it was incredibly
difficult and I do think the Chairman
avantco should be clear I'm nothing
they're gonna get pilloried the board
because they're gonna say why were you
giving these suits but it's cool when
you are in trouble for 10 years to
attract people to come in because they
know it's chancy you've got to pay him
quite a lot of money why this should be
rude not rewarding failure but they
should be performance yes you shouldn't
the bonuses should be based upon how
well you're doing
yeah and that's quite challenge but I
have a whole line yes you know I have a
whole concern about the sort of money
we're now paying to chief executives in
this country anyway I just think what
you you know the jobs that used to get a
couple of hundred grand a year now get
two and three million yeah and some of
it is mad I mean I'll stick up here for
my old employee gianlu it's where we
limit the highest-paid salary to 70
times the mt70108 if couldn't earn more
than a million quid I mean and that's
for somebody who's running running a
business it's turning over more than ten
million he went in a surgical you
probably get in 15 exactly the shoes
there now would probably walk be able to
walk up tomorrow and earn five ten times
what he earns have done this Michele's
central point is should the government
have bailed him out this is what Grant
Shapps had to say governments aren't
really in the business of running you
know tour operators and travel agents
and but actually more so it looked
pretty obvious that with 1.7 billion
pounds
debt a whole load of systemic problems
that we could easily have been putting
money up which would have been lost
taxpayers money which would have been
lost and still had to end up
repatriating bringing home all of these
British citizens stranded so in the end
I think it may boss a couple of weeks I
don't think it would have solved the
problem transport secretary Grant Shapps
and I think he's absolutely right it's
terribly sad and I think we all it's the
members of staff you feel for the most
some of whom were actually working even
knowing that it wouldn't get paid
they've been let go and they were still
trying to help people one interesting
point that comes out and I'll come to
you but we must go into Rachel she's not
how to say so just think on this the
idea of what's called activist
shareholders the ID you actually have a
shareholder who could act on that but
maybe you'll sink on that for a second
after we've heard from Rachel well it
makes me feel incredibly left-wing their
story I wouldn't have bailed it out but
I genuinely find it astonishing that a
company whose performance has gone from
bubbling along in between profit and
loss and then massive loss and the share
and the directors in the board still pay
themselves millions of pounds a year
they should be ashamed of themselves
they should be sat down in front of the
videos of those members of staff who are
working unpaid to repatriate British
citizens to this country and on a loop I
mean and they should apologize to those
I think government did fail because I
don't believe that they should have
bailed them out financially but if you
remember monarch went box and there was
a review that took place to look at what
happened and how can we avoid similar
things like the weekend creation anyway
so there was all of these examples and
suggestions that were put forward
including a seat levee there was a seat
levee that would actually have created a
fund that would have stopped it would
have protected the taxpayer from having
to bear those cost that was never
implemented
there was suggestions of changes to
insolvency rules that would have allowed
aircraft to carry on flying during that
period which currently they can you've
got to get other cut aircraft from
different carriers to bring them home so
that is where I think that the
government has let people down by not
implementing the lessons learned we can
we can talk about the directors money
and so on but to be fair let's I should
tell you what the chief executive said
in the midst of this debacle he said I
would like to apologize to our millions
of customers and thousands of employees
suppliers and partners who have
supported us for many years despite huge
uncertainty over recent weeks our team's
continued to put customers first showing
why Thomas Cook is one of the best-loved
brands in travel this marks a deeply sad
day for the company which pioneered
package holidays and made travel
possible for millions of people around
world no I haven't got a great deal
sympathy but the balance let's just
remember maybe they tried their best and
other part of this group are surviving
actually so you know I'm not going to
speak up for the benefit here let's
let's just bear in mind that maybe
they've got an explanation to
shareholder action grid I'm many
difference here the numbers that you
just show the dramatic fall off this
year out of nowhere you cash what do you
do and by the way it's a very quick bit
of context cuz everyone's saying you
can't have 9,000 people going onto the
doll and the government's just upset
when Woolworths went under there was at
least three times nearly 30,000 people
lost their jobs you want to advocate the
government getting in the billing house
by the way just constantly move on
Michelle can you do that yeah lady hail
spider